good morning John the other day I was on
Twitter and I noticed a hashtag in the
trending tab that I thought was
appealing it was appealing to me it said
nerd farters and I was like that's very
funny I wonder I wonder what that is and
honestly I was astounded to find that it
was the hashtag of an October
nerdfighter art prompt challenge that I
did not know existed I found out about
it through the trending tab on Twitter
which I famously disliked but I suppose
the product does deliver some useful
information maybe not some maybe just
one one piece of useful information
which was the existence of the
nerdfarters October nerdfighter art
prompt challenge so the story is dftba
Rachel had the idea ask people if they
would be interested and then sweet
Carolyn came along and said what if you
called it nerd farters people were into
it Rachel created this spooky graphic
that had a different prompt for each of
the 31 days in October we're almost
halfway through the month and I wanted
to share with you some of the genius
that has been created and I hope that
more will continue coming the first
prompt was simply dftba which people
went in a lot of different directions
with and since it's the first one I'll
go ahead and show you all of them that
were submitted I won't do that for any
of the other ones the great thing about
this is no one is really trying to be a
virtuoso except for Alice what the heck
Alice now I'm not going to tell you any
of my favorites of these but my favorite
is obviously the one where I get chased
by the crab with a knife our next prompt
Pizza John yourself which is
unexceptionally good prompt then we had
Breezy fall day which is a reference to
my second novel thank you for that
followed by just the word Pelican on
October 4th which is as delightful as
you would expect next we have surprise
fiddle concert which you could do
anything with and then nerdfighteria and
then pizzimus and then possibly my
favorite prompt of the whole month draw
a crab you have to do a bad job it is
one thing to be told that you can do a
bad job but I think that we need to
require ourselves to do a bad job more
often otherwise it's just too much
pressure and you will never do the thing
because you think you're bad at the
thing but you can't get better at the
thing if you don't do the thing going
deeper into the lore here now we have
French the llama and puppy-sized
elephant then we got million dollar idea
featuring surprisingly edible and the
awesome club club which look I'm not
saying we're gonna do that but I'm not
saying that we aren't going to do it
either then this Wednesday we had
pumpkins and Penguins unsurprisingly
full of delightful stuff including an
actual pumpkin because it is indeed
Halloween and then yesterday The Prompt
was hope is the thing with feathers but
I filmed this so early yesterday that
there weren't any posted yet so if you
want to see them you have to go look for
the Nerdfighters hashtag on Twitter or
follow nerdfarters on Twitter there were
of course way too many nerd farts for me
to post all of them in this video and it
only seems to have been growing
organically as the month has gone on and
I very much hope that this video will
inspire more people to go check it out
maybe submit a couple prompts to
yourself maybe you have to do a bad job
I really love all the prompts I'm
personally most looking forward to robot
Carl that's exciting for me Superior
fish beings is going to be amazing and
also of course just I'm very excited to
see your lemon man after all these years
of doing this and all of the other
things that we do I am very happy and
excited to not be in control of many of
the cool things that happen in this
community I think and call me crazy that
doing things is never about doing the
best thing I think that it is about
doing things and ideally doing things
with people that you like a lot and who
are cool and I am really feeling that
energy right now having discovered this
organically which is the strangest part
like I'd seen a couple of Arts but I
hadn't I hadn't like put it together
that it was part of a thing until the
hashtag just popped up which I guess is
why they do the hashtag I just wish it
wasn't constantly full of things that
make me angry and sad but sometimes it's
full of the thing that makes me happy
and
and what's the opposite of angry I don't
know what's the opposite of angry I
haven't figured it out let me know if
you know what the opposite of angry is
John I'll see you on Tuesday